now that pot is legal will you try seth
rogan's new weed he started a weed
company
you know what uh you know what i
occasionally do to mellow out a little
bit
the gummies oh gummies oh yes
yeah really you know the gummy is
yeah it doesn't have all the after
effects you take the gummy in an hour
and a half you're starving then you're
half in a bag what the hell
why not when you say you do the gummy i
know what you're talking about they
sell them like candy you gotta be very
careful with them because
you eat it and you think oh nothing
happened but then all these it takes 40
minutes
it takes 40 minutes and so you can't
take the full one because then you're
going to be completely out of it
so you got to be careful of how you
handle it and you know you do it when
you know you got five hours you're not
going to be bothered no radio to do and
everything else your kids are away you
could just you know
watch a ball game or something or watch
queen's gambit or something like that so
i
i would do that you're a high strung guy
you got a lot of opinions you're very
you know you're in your face
when you're on weed do you totally just
veg out or do you become the opposite of
chris
russo on the right now yes i veg yes yes
will you
ever videotape yourself or do a radio
show
would you come on here with your gums i
probably could
if you gave me a gummy you got to give
me 40 minutes i should try that one day
you know
what the hell yes i've never done that
how about i take a gummy at about 1 30
in the afternoon and i go through a
monologue at 305.
yeah how about using one together we'll
do a gummy together i'll get your gummy
you can put it in your yogurt i know you
want to work on the nutrition
put the yogurt in and we'll do three
hours you and me
you're gonna be mellow dog i know it
you